welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka definition and yes i changed my name
and hoped that nobody would notice
like elizabeth oldson's russian accent
look shut up for a second
because we put together a list of 52
insane details that we noticed in the
teaser trailer for one division
there might be some spoilers here in
regards to leaks on the show
so if you want to go in as blind as
possible then i recommend that you turn
off now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe otherwise i'll bloody snap you
i said i'll snap you now without the way
thank you for clicking this
let's get into the trailer okay so the
trailer opens with a black and white
marvel studios logo
which hammers home the aesthetic of this
piece the tv screen is also box format
which was common at the time due to
cameras not being designed to film in
white screen
the song twilight time by the plateaus
plays in the background
and this 1958 melody instantly sets the
mood of this sitcom
after the events of infinity war and
game wonder has clearly created her own
pocket reality
in which she now lives the life that she
wishes she got with vision
the witch is truly out in full force and
i love that the show is going back to
the true meaning behind her name
we actually see the fabric of reality
tear at one point in the trailer
cementing that she has indeed created an
alternate universe
that's where doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness is gonna come in
and it is rumored that he will be
dealing with the repercussions of her
creating this alternate place in time
and space
the madness in the title is also meant
to reference wonder
who is supposedly going to be crushed by
the ending of the show
after being forced to come back to
reality now this is why the mind stone
is back as well as vision
even though we know that both were
destroyed at the end of infinity war
the mine stone is of course tied to the
pair as it's what wonder received her
powers from
and it also gave vision life they can
both be seen driving along the road
and on the back of their car are the
words just married we might even get to
see this
and i think it would be hilarious if
some of the other dead mcu characters
were in attendance at their wedding
though i doubt it at the moment they
then cut to their home with wander in a
wedding dress
and vision in his suit the pair are
living a lever to beaver-esque existence
and it's clear that wonder has become
heavily influenced by the shows of old
have no idea how she's aware of these
american classics
but it is possible that when she was
growing up in russia
they were shown reruns of the old series
america used to sell a lot of its
programming to other countries so that
they could fill up their air time
and we might even get some glimpses at
her life as a child which will explain
this
on the newspaper that vision is holding
we can also see the headline
little baby june's first words tickle
her mother
considering the world has just survived
the devastation of the snap
this headline isn't what you'd expect to
see at all on a front page
showing that this is indeed a completely
separate reality
in which the only things that are making
the news are adorable stories about nice
and unhappy things basically the
opposite to 2020.
now wonder says that this is their home
now and either she
or vision transforms his face to be
similar to paul bettany so that he can
fit in
we saw this in infinity war but here it
gets it gets a low res effects makeover
to make it fit in more with this style
of the show
in the comic book vision which this show
is based on the titular character didn't
disguise himself
and thus he stuck out like a sore thumb
but i'm glad they're doing this so
people aren't just
staring at his purple head all the time
i kinda have a feeling that this is
gonna fall from bewitched
another classic sitcom in which a witch
and her husband
tried to blend in in middle america next
we see catherine hahn
who says it's gonna be a gas i think
that she's actually the villain of the
piece
and it was leaked that this would be
agatha harkness a powerful witch in the
marvel universe
harkness apparently teaches wonder how
to build a pocket universe
and then manipulates her when she's in
it if this is harkness
then she's clearly aware of what's going
on in the outside world
as she does say to vision in the trailer
that he's dead it
it was pretty pretty funny to be fair
now wonder then levitates a bottle of
wine
with the words maison du may pre written
on it
in french maison do means house of and
with the big m at the top of the bottle
this could be
could be a little nod to house of m in
that one that actually wipes out all the
mutants on earth by
saying no more mutants but there are
theories that in the show she will be
creating them and this is how the x-men
will be introduced to the mcu
the word may pre also means contempt in
french which further hammers home
that something is off we then see
deborah joe rupp
and she actually played kitty in that
70s show which
is another reference to sitcoms in
general she asks wonder
why she doesn't have any children yet
and this clearly rubs the character the
wrong way
as she ends up creating them later in
the entry i think that agatha has
actually erased their memories as both
wander and vision try and recall the
past
but they're unable to maybe ignorance is
just bliss
and wonder did this on purpose but
clearly they've had to forget
in order to move on it's nice that they
said that they had to move on as well
and then can't remember which
you know little little little bit of
foreshadowing there now
clearly she hasn't created the past part
of their reality yet
and it causes arthur played by fred
melamed to stop banging the table asking
why
ned ryerson bing wonder then rewinds
everything that we've seen in the
trailer so far and she creates a brand
new reality that looks like it's part of
the 70s
we did see in the original trailer that
a number of different eras are appearing
and perhaps she has to reset when things
all come crashing down
as this is an episodic series i can see
each episode taking place in a different
time
setting so it does make sense that she
keeps refreshing things
there's also a new aspect ratio which is
more fitting with modern times
you also see that agatha has joined her
and i tell you what
she looks like something out of the call
on me video maybe not as sexy but you
know i
i rate it now on top of this the pair
are holding babies
and this is likely the twins wicking in
speed in the comics the pair are
actually both vision and
wanders children and they are in fact
mutants if we are changing eras as well
it also makes sense that the pair will
grow up through the decades
so who knows we might actually see them
beyond simply being babies
we then cut to halloween and this
explains why both wonder and vision
appear in more comic book accurate
costumes designed from cloth
vision flies into the air and clearly
realizes that things are wrong
but he can't quite put his finger on it
i think that when he makes it up to the
top of wherever he's flying to
he'll realize he's in some sort of
prison and won't be able to get out
he then lands and sees catherine horn in
a car completely unresponsive
until he awakens her she asks if she's
dead
and then tells him that he is catherine
is also dressed like a witch
further cementing our theory about her
being agatha harkness
i think that she's someone that exists
in the real world and has been brought
in which is why she knows that the
vision is dead
i think vision touching her will
enlighten him quite a lot
and he will learn the truth about the
outside directly from the character
it also looks like he's using his powers
from the mind stone
which yet maybe she's after that and its
abilities
we then see the title a visionary new
age
which puns puns puns wonder once more
changes reality
hammering home that we will be seeing
different eras
we then join monica rambo being thrown
out of the reality
and she lands on the other side in the
real world you might remember that a
child version of the character appeared
in captain marvel
and it's great to see her all grown up
she actually becomes her own hero called
photon
so who knows this might be where she
gets her powers
we also see a military group and rumors
are that this is actually
agents of sword as they were leaked in
some behind the scenes images for the
show
they seem to have set up a perimeter
around the outside of the reality
and sent rambo in to investigate and god
i hope that guy returns from ant-man in
the wasp i just hope it
now that's the entire trailer and i have
to say that i absolutely loved it
marvel have been really quiet recently
and if the pandemic continues the way
it's going
this might actually be the only thing
set in the mcu that we see this year
however i am quite happy that it's at
least getting released for definite
and according to the schedule we'll be
seeing it in december with falcon and
the winter soldier
being delayed until 2021 either way this
has got me hyped
and looks like the mcu is gonna be going
in a great new direction with their new
tv shows
and it's gonna be a gas now obviously
i'd love to your thoughts on the trailer
in the comments below
so make sure you drop them and if
there's anything we missed i'd love to
hear it unless i'm in a bad mood that
day in which
i'll bloody block you now if you want
something else to watch
then definitely check out our theories
on the boys which is gonna be linked at
the end
we discuss who we think black noir and
stormfront really are
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch
don't forget we're also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of september so make sure
you get involved
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on the
discord server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you